hi I'm Matt Steiner matt is a certified
senior crime scene analyst he's
demonstrated how to live fingerprints
and analyze blood stain patterns in
technique tutorial area today I'm going
to show you how forensic analysts
determined bullet trajectory in this
episode we'll learn the methods experts
use to investigate a shooting theme
increasing the complexity with each step
firearms are used at many crime scenes
so to analyze the evidence that's left
behind it's very important before we can
start plotting a bullets trajectory we
need to know something about ballistics
ballistics is the analysis of a
projectile motion forensic ballistics
focuses on firearms-related projectiles
there's internal ballistics external
ballistics and terminal ballistics
internal ballistics is what happens
inside that gun external ballistics is
what happens to that bullet once it
leaves the muzzle of that weapon and
finally terminal ballistics is what
happens when that bullet strikes that
target understanding these three
categories it's important because
they're all related that that bullet
that comes from the gun takes a path and
then goes into a surface when we go and
testify front of a jury we have to
educate them they don't know the
difference between a cartridge a casing
and a bullet and there are three
different things so what we have here
are unfired cartridges these would go
inside of a weapon and then when they
are fired they are separated into
different components so now we're
looking at shell casings after we fire
that cartridge this is either gonna
remain inside the weapon or be ejected
out of the weapon when that cartridge
casing is fired the bullet is going to
come out of the barrel of the weapon
this bullet is in pretty pristine
condition
I believe this one was fired into a tank
of water and recovered so we don't see a
lot of deformation on it but I do see
the rifling on that bullet so I know it
was fired from a weapon as these bullets
strike different targets they're gonna
deform in different ways they flatten
out they hit an object at an angle and
are dented or they pass through
something soft like this bullet and that
bullet and then sometimes when these
bullets hit surfaces they will fragment
when we're at a crime scene task to
determine if we have ballistic
trajectories or if we have ballistic
damage there the presence of a bullet
especially a bullet that's been damaged
could help us in figuring out whether
that damage was created by a bullet or
from some other means next up we're
gonna show how these bullets show up at
a crime scene now that we've seen
cartridges casings and bullets let's see
how they affect our crime scene so when
we encounter ballistic damage at a crime
scene we want to first figure out if we
have a hole
what is the entrance and what is the
exit so if we look around the perimeter
of our entrance we see a dark substance
this is what's called bullet light as
that bullet travels down a barrel we
have burnt gunshot residue and residue
inside the barrel that's being picked up
on the bullet as it travels from the
muzzle of the weapon and as it passes
through our surface it wipes that
residue off so if I had a bullet that
enters on this side exits on that side
re-enters another surface and Arie exits
I could tell which side it entered first
because doesn't have any more residues
to wipe off with the exit we could see
here that the fibers of the wood are
going in the direction of the bullet why
was a little different than solid wood
would be but with this or what metal we
would see that substrate pushed in the
direction of the exit Bharani entrance
side we would see it pushed in so when I
look at this bullet hole entry I could
tell us directionality understanding
directionality is one of the keys to
figuring out what happened and how it
happened what I see is the parabolic
shape of the bullet as it first comes in
contact with the surface and I know it's
traveling from left to right because of
that you shape another occluded
directionality for us by looking at this
is on this bullet hole where the bullet
doesn't actually penetrate the surface
but glances along it to first tell
directionality by first looking at that
you shape that parabolic shape and then
we also notice is that the shape is very
symmetrical on the front of it but as
it's traveling from left to right it
becomes asymmetrical so that bullet is
being deformed as it's moving along the
surface creating this asymmetrical
damage we just talked about
directionality as it relates to
entrances and exits now we're gonna add
a layer of complexity to it so on the
car door we can see that bullets are
coming from a couple different
directions so we can tell these are all
entrances because the way the metal is
deforming in a direction of the bullet
we have very circular entrance holes
here here and here these shots are
coming pretty straight on perpendicular
to that surface with our bullet hole
entry that's going from right to left
here I know it's going that way because
a certain key Clues what I'm looking at
is the point that the bullet strikes the
surface first and creates a shoulder
that goes into the car door so another
key to directionality on this first
bullet hole entry is that we have an
area of preserved paint right at the
edge here so that's called a pinch point
so the pinch point is where the bullet
first comes in contact with the painted
door and it's preserving that area and
then as the bullet travels further in
this case from right to left it's going
to enter the car door and create damage
so we see that the paint has flaked off
around it but it's been being preserved
right here where the pinch point is next
we're gonna calculate the angles in
which this bullet entered this car door
at a crime scene we measure out the
specific location of each bullet hole
entry and ballistic impact mark fixing
it to the world so from the ground to an
edge of a door to a wall this is used
quite frequently in shooting
reconstruction cases where we want to
show where that bullet is coming from so
this can be time-consuming on big scenes
where we have a lot of evidence we may
want someone who's just trained in this
to do this sort of work because this
could take hours first gonna calculate
the vertical angle we use that in
kilometer or digital and kilometer to
get this measurement so right now we
have a measurement of 10 degrees
downward next we're going to calculate
the azimuth angle that's the left or
right or the right-to-left angle so what
we want to do is place our zero point at
90 degrees there's a line there lining
up exactly where that bullet strikes the
surface first I'm gonna have Johnathan
come in give me a hand with this next we
can take a plumb bob and on the interior
side of that angle we're gonna drop it
and hold it alongside our zero based
protractor our line is striking the zero
based protractor at somewhere around 23
degrees when we document this is
traveling from right to left 23 degrees
now we're going to attach a laser to the
end of our trajectory rod to visualize
its trajectory this is used quite
frequently in shooting reconstruction
cases or
want to show where that bullet is coming
from so in order to see this and
document it through photography we're
gonna have to dim the lights so I'm
spraying along the line if I was
photographing it I would do a long
exposure so this would be captured over
time another method to show this
trajectory line would be to reflect
light back towards the camera by
reflecting off a white card and over
time if I did a long exposure I could
show that line so if I had this as a
Venice at a crime scene
our bullet hole entries we put a
trajectory rod in for each one the more
ballistic damage we have the more work
it's going to be if I had a case let's
say where a bullet came through a window
and struck a wall but didn't enter the
wall I could do trajectory at that with
string I detach one end this string to
the damage on the wall and then bring
that string and run it through the hole
in a window and that also would give us
the area where that bullet came from the
advantage of string is that it's easy to
photograph during daylight where the
laser we'd have to make the area dark
and then that's not possible when the
Sun is out we just finished with lasers
our next step is to use the 3d laser
scanner so we're going to be using the
Leica RTC 360 to capture our crime scene
so the laser scanner and with the Leica
software not only can we get very
precise measurements we can also get
those same angles that we calculated
with the trajectory rod so we're gonna
set up our laser scanner in two
different positions and scan this scene
after we scan the scene we're then gonna
import that data into software so we
could visualize our point cloud so now
that we have our two scans we've
imported into our Leica software
anything that's in the view the scanner
is going to be captured so you can see
us offset here there's me
so the RTC 360 to take about 2 million
measurements per second so as it spins a
full 360 all these measurements will
look like one large point cloud the
beauty of laser scanning is that unlike
a static image we can move it around we
could view it from different angles we
could see these trajectory rods that we
have in place and we can get novel views
of the scene that we couldn't get with
traditional video or photography and
one of the great things about laser
scanning is that its objective any other
type of measurements that we take at a
crime scene I'm choosing to measure from
two points or three points to this
evidence with the Leica scan anything
that's in its field of view it's
documenting it so we may not know that
something over here is valuable and we
don't collect it we don't photograph it
and we miss it but later on as our
investigation proceeds we find out oh
this was really important at least it's
captured with laser scanner what also we
could show with this is our cone of
Tolerance so with trajectory analysis
there's a built-in plus or minus five
degrees of error with this software I
could show that error so I've created a
line from two points on that rod and now
I could take that line and extend it out
into space and sometimes in real crime
scenes this becomes very important I had
a reconstruction that we did where a
bullet went through the 13th floor
window of a business and then wanted to
see where that bullet came from so we
scanned inside of the business and in
several blocks around it on the street
and we're able to trace that trajectory
about 800 feet away two blocks away from
the location so today we talked about
the basics of ballistic analysis these
skills are built over time taking
hundreds of hours of courses you know
more scenes more experience the better
you get at it hopefully our viewers but
better understanding of shooting
reconstruction as well as the physics
math and science behind it I find bullet
trajectory fascinating and I hope you do
[Music]